a un mes de la reunión de los líderes
mundiales por la cob 26 finalizó su
preludio la cumbre climática juvenil en
milán con demandas muy distintas a las
de los gobiernos los lideres
medioambientales jóvenes exigieron
acción inmediata somos imparables otro
mundo es posible
la esperanza no viene del blablabla de
los políticos la esperanza no viene de
las inacciones de las promesas vacías de
que todo irá bien ellos dicen confía en
nosotros que hacemos todo lo que podemos
pero eso no es esperanza la esperanza es
esto somos nosotros el pueblo la
esperanza es cuando la gente se reúne
para hacer el cambio la cita de you for
climate reunió a cerca de 400 líderes
medioambientales de todo el mundo en
italia el evento fue el punto de partida
para otra manifestación de los friday's
for future hasta hace poco paralizados
por la pandemia
el valor
un futuro quiero tener un futuro este es
nuestro planeta y lo tenemos que
proteger no importa lo mayores que
seamos necesitamos protegerlo para
nosotros y para las futuras generaciones
espero que con estas manifestaciones los
políticos empiecen a aplicar lo que han
prometido hasta ahora espero que nos
escuchen los jóvenes exigen que sus
peticiones de políticas ecológicas
transparentes turismo sostenible y el
fin de los combustibles fósiles para
2030 sean escuchadas paralelamente a la
marcha ministros climáticos de varios
países se reunieron para preparar la cob
26 y combatir con urgencia la crisis
climática